tu es né sur un ouais bien alors on va
faire une première fois dans la bouche
pendant le gala pays qui est bien dans
une réponse avec l'accent belge dès hier
de liège et des plumes des plus beaux
survient gilles et puis je suis allé au
rythme d'envoi à faire l'interview
première fois mais avec l'accent non
oui vraiment vous fait vachement bien
bougé pendant le récent plan d'aidé
belge qui regarde à walia tous les
liégeois je vous embrasse très fort
voilà c'est bien on avait julie snyder
noir malgré moi ça fait déborder une
belle nana c'est exactement ce que je
pense des québécoises - bonsoir
gilles ménage qui est là bonsoir alors
votre premier souvenir
l'accent est à dire avec l'accent
premier souvenir
le premier souvenir le sourire de ma
mère
non je peux pas dire ça mais pas comme
ça
pourquoi accent mais c'est beaucoup
mieux de ce premier choc de votre vie
moi quand j'ai appris que le père noël
n'existait pas on peut pas dire qu'on va
quand j'ai appris que le père noël
n'existait pas j'ai été vraiment choqués
non mais oui mais ça fera du tout le
monde suit l'accord jolie fille comme ça
et ça tu sais plus c'est pourquoi être
chez moi je fais ça pour pas être
amoureux bon maintenant je vous libère
de l'accent belge parce qu'on rentre
dans des questions compliquées
donc je ne veux pas que vous soyez on
retient de perturber prend l'accent
cynisme premiers amours premières amours
martin il s'appelait martin était plus
âgée que vous non même âge même âge quel
âge à quel âge c'était
cédant à 16 ans faisaient attendu 16 ans
oui j'étais très près d'un trait aux
minguettes ça quel âge luis région vous
aimez ces dangers graves aussi je
connais suivante je me la poser à
premier visé exactement fernandez il
pourrait la faire à ma place c'est
tennis au premier baiser premier baiser
c'était dans la cour de l'école en fait
je fantasmais sur un type et je crois
que je l'échoppé il était en short
c'était un cours de gym un et je ne sais
pas pourquoi je me suis avancé vers lui
et j'ai embrassé sur la bouche
ça a été assez magique ouais voilà
c'était exactement comme avec le kiné
dambach mais finalement vous avez pas
beaucoup changé ça c'était sans la
langue ou avec la langue sans
enregistrements les premiers baisers
avec la langue était moins bien
ah bon pourquoi ça vous dégoûter la
langue non mais je m'en étais fait tout
un monde enfin mais en fait non non non
avant c'était qui hervé benhaddou il
s'appelait en ont les géniaux bon
premier flirt poussé flirt poussé 20
c'était c'était à 17 ans dans une cabane
dans la crau l'inla la première fois
pour de vrai à d'accord mais maintenant
le flou repoussée parce que j'entends je
pas commencé en belgique parce que
j'entends parfois repoussé complet
beaucoup de choses mais on ne fait pas
la chose moi je me rappelle que de là
vraiment la bagarre allait d'acord
s'est-elle alors dans la game vous
manger quoi manger des miels potes vous
a marqué la première fois à trois et
vous mets toi c'est à troyes dans l'aube
donc ça va
il ya trop longtemps problème c'est que
c'est avec mon meilleur ami et sa
fiancée et ses parents sinon je laurent
laurent bonjour d'hier et papilles bon
d'accord première fois à 4 arcade au
premier chagrin d'amour
à combien là parce que j'ai du mal à
suivre
premier chagrin d'amour la première fois
oui moi je devais avoir 20 ans j'étais
amoureuse d'un funambule qui m'a laissé
tomber comme une vieille chaussette pour
travailler proportionnelle fil des tongs
première cuite première cuite et je
crois en pologne
en plus du tout comme un polonais ont
des vêtements pologne sont jamais mis
trop de vodka ont tourné dans les tatras
on était dans un hôtel qui ressemble un
peu à celui de shining voilà donc on se
console est temps qu'on pouvait dans la
vodka première cigarette au cabanis
jours qui viennent par caen dans vos
émissions vous poser la question sur le
cabanis d'accord avec moi première
cigarette au cabanis ya pas très
longtemps c'était à la jamaïque avait
marqué vous bourrez en pologne
vous fumez vous fumez verbal jamaïque
vous êtes quelque chose au bon endroit
en grèce
et en avait blessé bien première chose
que vous faites le matin en vous
réveillant jeu marrant d'aller très
bonnes vacances
dernière chose que vous faites le soir
avant de vous coucher je me passe de la
crème sur les pieds sur les pieds
maintenant que moi et avant de vous
endormir dernière chose que vous faites
c'est quoi avant de vous coucher ou
mettez de la crème sur les pieds
cette armée de bouchons de la grève
avant de vous endormir
non je parle pas de trucs de sexe vous
pouvez faire une prière vous pouvez
faire votre examen de conscience
voilà lumière sincère quand vous dites
ça
avec un bibal fabrice luchini et
dans mardi laisser de vide manque
variété de bruno chiche voilà merci
beaucoup
avant d'acquérir une invitée suivant
quelques him